[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com okay i'm having a major
problem in my apartment here in boston
and it was insane is i had this problem
when i was 14 and lived at my mom's
house that's already laughing I don't
know why this is so funny already to you
you had a problem with your reports
heated with your mouth and i'm having
the same problem now here's the thing i
don't even know how to explain what's
going on basically my house makes noises
my apartment makes noises and they come
from the wall and it's sort of like a
cracking noise and i know exactly I know
exactly what's going on now it's not a
monster the issue is that in the winter
months when you have the heat on it will
sometimes cause joints beams whatever in
the walls to sort of shift expand and
contract slightly and it causes these
really loud cracking noises and I was
finding that it was preventing me from
sleeping through the night so for
example I I have one of those
energy-efficient like timer thermostats
and the way I have it set is like around
10pm or something like that it'll go
from 70 degrees down to 62 because I
don't really need the heat on during the
night now it won't actually ever get
down to 62 right so like during the
night it's only enough time for the
temperature to drop to like 65 or
something like that I guess because
you're in bed and you're already covered
up you don't need it to be too too warm
I am much more comfortable sleeping in
cooler temperatures it'll get down to 65
66 great with peace and love I sleep
it's called fantastic right but the
problem is I had it set up to kick back
on to get us back up to 70 69 70 degrees
at 7am so that when my alarm goes off at
740 it's warmer and it's all great right
and it works fantastically the issue was
the heat would go on at seven and
immediately the entire house is making
noise it's shimmying and it's shaking
and it's cracking and popping and making
all these noises and its really very
loud so I thought okay here's what I
need to do the temperature is 65 when
the when it kicks back on at seven a.m.
and going up forward
five degrees it's a big change in
temperature so what if instead I
configure it to turn on earlier and more
slowly raise the temperature yeah from
what I've heard you're only supposed to
adjust it two or three degrees at a time
so that way you're not putting too much
stress on the system itself well the
system i'm not worried about but it's
more that the house seems to be under
stress but fair point point taken so
instead what I've taken to doing is
setting it so that at four thirty in the
morning it'll go to 66 degrees and at
five thirty in the morning it'll go to
67 degrees and it really a vanity yeah
so I thought this will be better because
we're not going to have these big
changes as it happened the last three
nights I got up and woke up and looked
around and noticed that at one point it
was for 37 in the morning this morning
it was 540 in the morning right so
within 10 minutes of a temperature
escalation and the walls are cracking
and popping and I'm up again so I I
genuinely don't know how to deal with
this when I look online it's tons of
people talk about how ya old houses new
houses apartments whatever when you have
winter and you have heat going in
between your walls through ductwork it
will cause these shifts and the wooden
beams being you know presumably like the
beams we have here to some degree and
it's going to make that noise I am at a
loss here I don't know what to do the
other option would be just don't have
the heat turn on at all right just get
up and it'll be 65 degrees another
option I guess would be instead of
letting it just drop during the night
set it 67 and keep it at 67 and maybe
I'll just get up and not warm it up
anymore and deal with that I don't know
right there's no easy solution there I
mean you could kind of find the happy
medium temperature where you're just
comfortable all the time whether you
have blankets on or not or I guess it's
you know it's a lot easier to bundle up
during cooler temperatures and it is to
cool down I guess what yeah that's hot
yeah so I don't know if there's needs a
solution there David yeah I think maybe
I need to try instead of going from 7265
during the night maybe I just drop it to
68 or something like that and dump it
there and then I don't need to have it
kick on in the morning to raise the
temperature or something like that
it's just I find 68 too hot for sleeping
just fundamentally right and I feel like
these cracking noises are not a pleasant
thing to wake up to know it sort of like
i think i can actually mirror it let's
see if this will take the noise is kind
of like this oh wow periodically like
that from the wall yeah and it's
sometimes every 45 seconds it's frequent
enough that I'm like anticipating the
next one and can't fall back asleep are
you a light sleeper not particularly
yeah how is there anything I've quite
last through fire alarm I mean it's not
that well like that wouldn't happen to
me but yeah so anyway that's what's
going on it's drama speaking of drama
major internal drama among progressive
media there's a whole bunch of specific
disagreements going on right now and
I'll you may not be following this so
I'll tell you about some of them so like
for example Kyle kolinsky host of
secular talk was engaged in a big
Twitter battle with dave rubin of the
reuben report and they were going at it
dave rubin and Jenke ogre were embroiled
in some kind of controversy that was
posted to our reddit this morning david
titled iono saying a couple times is in
posted but certainly there was one post
this morning about it as we know nicole
sandler and abby martin were slamming me
last week or the week before last week
because I interviewed Richard Spencer
even though RT and Al Jazeera and all
sorts of other news outlets had also BBC
had interviewed Richard Spencer so
there's a whole bunch of of these
internal disagreement and we had a
caller last week talk about whether we
think that the left is fractured in some
way I don't know that these internal
disagreements reflect the fracturing of
the left other then to some degree when
it comes to issues of like free speech
and no platforming and that type of
thing but i think that overall this
isn't particularly good for the
progressive movement and by that i mean
on the one hand we need the progressive
movement figuring out whether a more
corporatist centre-left democratic
approach or a more Bernie Sanders
approach is better for the Democratic
Party going forward if we believe the
future of progressivism is in the
Democratic Party not everybody does
that's a really worthwhile and necessary
debate but
sort of angry in fighting through social
media and whatnot that we've been seeing
that I've been targeted by and that as i
mentioned jank and dave and kyle quincey
and others have been involved in i don't
know in what way that's useful to the
movement I mean maybe people are just
still kind of hung over from Trump's
victory but I honestly think that had
Hillary Clinton won and the Democrats
won control back of the Senate had like
a big successful elections go around it
might have been worse because once your
party is in charge there tends to be a
lot of infighting there and you don't
know whether to kind of play the party
line or you put forward primary
challengers so I think that divide would
have happened regardless I that's why
before the election I kept saying no
matter what the results are of this
election progressive independent media
is going to be needed and what I meant
was if Hillary Clinton had one we still
would have had a Republican House and
Senate we would have had a very centrist
Democrat in the White House that's
generous to that is and maybe i'm being
generous and it would have been an
opportunity to number one to push the
democratic president to be as left as
possible which would have been a
challenge but also to prevent republican
obstructionism to the things that
hillary clinton would have done that we
would have agreed with and I don't know
that people were taking that so
seriously like the election of Donald
Trump has made a lot of progressives
take much more seriously the need for
independent media and for cohesive left
activism but I don't know whether it
would have been taken as seriously at
Hillary Clinton won and I worry that
there might have been what you're
suggesting might have happened which is
big big infighting among the left if you
get a corporate of sort of friendly
centre-left Democrat like Hillary
Clinton elected but it also might have
pacified people placated them and made
them not be too active so the escalation
of involvement i think is great i guess
my question is how do these internal
sort of spats between left-wing hosts
help the movement and i'm not sure that
they do i mean i think it also comes
down to the fact that tile kolinsky and
dave rubin are just ideologically quite
different yet they even throw in the
young turks there as well dave rubin
describes himself as a classical liberal
i guess that kind of means libertarian
nowadays the the meaning of that
over time and I don't know the best way
to describe Kyle maybe just a true First
Amendment type progressive yes when you
have a difference of opinion i mean
there's going to be disagreements and
sometimes those are aired on twitter
unfortunately sometimes they evolve into
ad hominem attacks and you're not going
after people's you know the things about
them personally yeah and obviously
that's a disaster and i think that i'm
not i'm not advocating some sort of like
fabricated or artificial total agreement
between all sides of the left because
that also is just not realistic and
there has to be the debates that happen
i just am advocating for more
discussions about what the progressive
goals and ideals should be rather than
sort of attack and i think that's that's
basically what you're getting up one
interesting note after the quebec mosque
shooting i sort of alluded to this
yesterday in our coverage initially
there were two individuals detained by
police the actual alleged shooter
alexander bissonnet and a moroccan guy
and there were some early reports that
maybe they were both suspects eventually
though police said the moroccan guy was
a witness he was not a suspect we have
only one suspect who we believe to be
the perpetrator and it's this
anti-feminist pro Trump white dude named
Alexander bissonnet Fox News tweeted
that it was this Muslim Moroccan in
whatever right you can sort of imagine
what Fox News tweeted and that was an
inaccurate tweet and Prime Minister of
Canada Justin Trudeau demanded that Fox
News delete that tweet because even just
leaving it out this problematic and Fox
News has actually done it and I think
that that's great I don't now think fox
news has come over to the side of actual
ference betfair in balance or whatever
it is they tout but this was the right
move and I'm glad that Fox News did it
they did make the right move its kind of
tough when you take down a tweet because
it's kind of shows that you're you're
expressing some regret and I don't think
they were trying to how do I should i
say this i don't think they were trying
to hide the fact of who this perpetrator
was trying to play it off as if it
wasn't some white guy it was some rockin
instead but i mean even though
tweets will still be in people's news
feeds for hours and days later a lot of
fox news viewers may not second-guess it
may not see the updated tweets so I
think in that respect you probably
should take it down yeah i mean the
removal of a tweet is sort of a quiet
action right right sort of like
everybody sees the headline very few
people see the correction at the back of
the newspaper because there's a much
quieter thing to do you send out a tweet
thousands tens of thousands of your
followers retweet it and integrate it
into their minds as a reality it was a
Moroccan dude who carried out the
Moroccan Muslim guy you don't then go
back to confirm whether tweets have been
deleted right you just move on it with
your days days later and you've just
moved on and it's very quiet in that
sense yeah it's Fox News Fox News I
don't even know how many followers they
have but I'd imagine it's what hundreds
of thousands or millions is a lot up
there yeah no I mean they have a big
following even if you take down a tweet
it's still going to be screencapped by
someone it's still going to be out there
so maybe that's how they rationalize not
taking it down to our foot one called
out upon it it's a good thing that they
made the right move here it's amazing
there's a similarity between what's
going on in Canada and here which is
that Twitter is just becoming a bigger
and bigger part of sort of politics
right Trump now communicates very
frequently the president communicates
insanely frequently through twitter
twitter makes news regularly we quote
lawmakers through their tweets all the
time on the show Justin Trudeau you
could say who cares what's on a social
media network what we're more concerned
with is insert anything else but the
Prime Minister specifically demanded the
deletion of a tweet later found to be
inaccurate twitter has got a front row
seat here to Western Hemisphere politics
well I don't think you're going to go
out and have a press conference over
something that seems kind of trivial
like this I mean this is kind of like a
side point yeah i think it's it's kind
of the right move for a Justin Trudeau
to put it out on Twitter or on some
other social media platform rather than
calling too much attention to it I agree
with you I agree with you but the role
of twitter has been significant over the
last election cycle okay that does it
for today's bonus show thanks to all of
our paid subscribers who of course get
the bonus show and all the other great
member benefits if you ever don't know
how to access one or another of the
different member benefits feel free to
email into the con
david patten.com i want to make sure
everybody knows how to access all of the
stuff we have available symmetric so
always feel free to guess what the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]